hello and welcome to this video I'm
happy to announce that I have something
new released on chesil yeah I did it is
the English opening repertoire that I
had previously developed for just 24 as
a video series and this is now available
also in chasuble format as you can see
on the left hand side it's currently
already on the side you can buy it for
9.99 u.s. dollars this is the initial
sale price and it will increase to
fifteen or fourteen point 99 um in early
2017 we probably will stop the sale once
we hit the new year so um what is it all
about
let's go into it and see what what's
going on it's completely fresh it does
not have any comments yet so um for
those of you who know how a chasuble
works this will be nothing new but I
want to briefly show how the the site
actually um yeah manages to teach you
this opening repertoire it is a complete
opening repertoire based on the move 1
c4 as you can see in the little diagram
we will start with the with the bishops
points you form and everything
absolutely everything that black might
throw at you is covered without
transposing into mainline d4 territory
then this is also what for to see in the
texts probably a little bit a little bit
on the on the small side for you to read
but it is some a pure English reti
opening repertoire there is just one or
two cases there's one case in the dutch
for example where i recommend to play 1d
form play d4 to transpose but this will
be this a very specific variation which
is not a huge effort to learn so you
don't need any
books or something like that there's
never a point where I'm going to say
okay guys here you need to get a
traditional book or whatever here
you don't need additional material if
you want of course you can expand your
repertoire and I give many suggestions
um if you look at this here on the left
hand side it shows you some details
about this book and it has 547
variations as it it calls this quality
on chasuble
and we have 150 alternative variations
and 53 info variations what does that
mean this totals to over 700 and if you
know how chasuble works you will know
that this is quite quite a quite a lot
my Benko repertoire roughly 300 for
example so alternative variation means
that I'm suggesting a main move but I
mentioned alternatives that you can also
play in some cases this will be really
early on like let's say after d4 Knight
f6 my main move is c4 Knight f6 g3 it's
my main move but I also mentioned that
Knight c3 is a good move but this is
just an alternative that points you to
other ideas it shows - to illustrate
what what possibilities are possible and
proper English right info variations
means this is just these are mostly
warning variations don't do that those
are the informational ones and we have
instruction of roughly 19,000 words
which is quite a bit I try to put in
many many explanations however um it is
a really huge repertoire and there will
be quite a number of positions where I
just give a simple wide a slightly
better white is clearly better one or
one of those things because some value
you have to limit yourself to - what
year - what you do and we also recommend
this for advanced players here on on
chasuble
and which means like 1800 and above you
can also benefit from from this
repertoire if you are lower rated but it
will make life a little bit more
difficult because there are those
situations where just saying white is a
bit better which is a stronger player
probably intuitively understands why
this is the case well somewhat less
experienced player would probably
benefit from more explanation so it is a
variation heavy repertoire and yeah how
does that work that learning process we
can we can check this out you go on
learn and now we start to learn let's do
this
yep so c4 I will move and it gives the
instructional text em okay what move
should act like I hope we don't fail
right here so c4 yeah okay I call c4
here it is kind of silly because we
really really knew that it is about c4
but then all we see chapter progress
this is an intro chapter by the way and
then we're going to see a couple of
replies in the intro chapter that is an
overview of the whole thing so after b6
we will go in form and it makes you put
this on the board so you really learn by
seeing the moves and being forced in a
way to reproduce what you do yeah in
many cases we will almost always go to
g3 but now here we learned the outline
so we go G 3 against F 5 for example and
so on and this is the way the way to do
it you will always see your progress in
percentages yeah
now here we also go g3 this is a nice
thing about this repertoire the first
couple of moves are always somewhat
somewhat identical yeah
oh gee three now this is just the intro
we of course drill a lot deeper yep in
93 for standard setup so it's an
interesting way to learn you don't
really have to yeah get out of the book
put this on on a real board and your
back and forth it shows you your
progress and let's go let's go for one
more yeah let's go for one more night f6
we play g3 and you always have the the
text here right like this 90 f6 it would
often transport to other part depending
on blacks choice of porn setup yeah
that's definitely true so we here we
just see okay we play the fee and keto
but we don't drill much deeper this is
done in a separate chapter of course so
again g3 push up G to those those moves
come pretty naturally because we will
make them in almost all cases would be
embarrassing if I don't don't know my
own repertoire right and it can happen
in a deeper line certainly will okay
this is the the basic way it is working
you also have other views on this
repertoire for example you have a tree
view here where you can go through yeah
it always starts with c4 thankfully so
c4 and now we see we have 191 variations
with E 5 164 with c6 e 6 in 135 c5 and
99 it looks a bit surprising that c6 has
so many variations the reason is that
the answer there is fairly complicated
um in those cases by the way let's say
c6 my main recommendation of course is
g3 it fits with with the rest of the
repertoire but I also do mention
alternatives like you can go d4 you can
play 93 even if or is a move here so if
you absolutely dislike the main
variation I will have plenty of give
plenty of alternatives along the way
that you could use if you
somehow don't like the position tybor
it's it feels too too much or whatever
so there are many alternatives given
this is if we go back to this view why
we have from those many alt alternative
variations in some cases there are
really a number of a number of
alternatives the English is a very
flexible opening which makes it yeah
very good for the practical player you
can vary your play a lot you know you
can go c4 and make a completely
different game out of it by your choices
later so what we could do also I can if
you go into the sorry into them into the
tree view I could show you some some
lines that are featured i've by the way
also made a video on on the subject or
in this repertoire itself when the video
was released so it might make sense to
check my channel for the video on them
just 24 wheelies in video form so what
is the general outline after E 5 we go G
3 and Bishop g2 yeah here black has a
couple of choices in the C 45 and setup
he can play the reversed open here with
d5 which as you see has the most
variations 58 I don't know if you can
actually see that on the video it's a
little bit it's a little bit it is a
little bit small problem so after d5 we
go for the reversed dragon and I'm I
selected this line here with rook b1
which is a tricky line black has to be
very very knowledgeable here to avoid a
slightly worse position for example
after castles we go before which is
already quite tricky for black to handle
as captures are answered with with
tactical shots and we have a great
center there this line with rook be one
with
back is a tricky choice not easy at all
for black to handle and of course in the
english IAM black has a couple of other
options and move that very often is
given as a good reply to g3 and it is
not a bad reply in c6 here ad form is
the main line but in recent years the
move Knight f3 has caught up in
popularity and I think that this is a
very interesting choice for white we
have a position like that on and my
experience is that black players don't
handle this very well I've been very
successful with this line in blitz
especially considering the position that
I got you sometimes screw it up later
but I got really great positions out of
this and black players are more focused
on other continuations like this which
is perfectly fine um and for example I
analyzed in in some books here by
Mahatma in the Romanian theoretician but
I felt that Knight f3 a zone is a good
alternative and not as well explored um
so we go g3 here against u5 and we also
go g3 against Knight f6 this is
important because black might play d5 to
transpose in general we will always play
Bishop g2 Knight c3 unless black plays
with a 6 yeah in a d6 setup we go to go
to that Bishop g2 do you find that
should transpose yeah here we don't play
in early 93 and yeah here my setup
involves and early b3 the ready system
here I've chosen some lines that are
extremely safe where white can yeah only
loose if he plays a kind of suicidal
chess but can try for 4 for small
advantages um another principle to apply
to c4 c5 of course the symmetrical one I
go again for g3 and
this is for example the symmetrical way
I recommend to move a three trying for a
quick before this is a very solid line
for black and white cannot expect a huge
advantage if any advantage all but you
get some interesting positions and what
you never should underestimate this is
not comparable to let's say yeah if you
remember game twelve of the recently
concluded World Championship match where
all pieces got traded in twenty five
moves this is not happening here this
might be equal but it's a full board
full of pieces with ideas to play for so
it is not a bad fighting weapon at all
because there are very few lines where
them where we have mass trades of
material I really expected the English
to feature in this world championship
mention I was very surprised that this
didn't happen because it's a good way
for Y to as they say get a game um so c5
we answer symmetric we play with g3 and
then stillness is six as mentioned as a
as an as an alternative for black again
we go g3 and this is actually a fairly
extensive part of this repertoire
because this line here the so called
Reggie gambit is quite um quite a tricky
line for black to handle but also quite
sharp
if black snatches the pawn and this is a
pretty big part of this of this
repertoire 1066 variations alone and
because it is complicated white often is
a pawn down but has good compensation
this is some I believe a very good line
to play even if you are not a very
dynamic player at heart it just helps
you to broaden your yeah you are let's
say repertoire of position types that
you play so you should not just play
always like be 3 to 3 and slowish but
also at one one point or another
sacrifice a pawn for dynamic play as
mentioned and I give a couple of
alternatives early on if you really
don't like this so much and ya against
it six we we do the red yes as we said
an idea six is mostly transposition
now we play g3 sometimes black goes from
Kings Indian setup in this case we set
up something like this where black again
has a choice now we can play see 585
yeah go for something that we have seen
in other chapters often they stay within
the Kings Indian territory and I usually
go for lines like this where white
basically handles it like an e5
variation and goes for a quick before
for example if black now plays in five
which is very common we will play before
and we transpose into something that
usually comes from c-45 white has a
pretty nice position here on the Queen
side and yeah definitely be a
complicated game ahead so the English is
are very flexible opening and as
mentioned we have very little
transpositions also note the move list
yeah I really looked at everything even
a6 or g5 and the only case there's no
case where transpose into a d4 opening
by the way after f5 if they play a
classical Dutch a field here and after
d6 like this this that defaults really
the best move and it just leads to a
slight advantage for white so all in all
it is a good standalone
ya package of ideas and lines um let's
go back to the to the main view I wonder
what else is there yeah I think M and an
input and an interesting thing for you
to mention is you see the comment
section and it was it was really empty
when I started the video but it this has
been released a couple of minutes ago
and they are already two comments here
so if you buy this repertoire and you
are accessible user you can put in those
comments and also ask me questions like
what about this line why did you include
this why didn't you choose that one
warm why is that particular line missing
because everybody makes mistake
and there will be mistakes in this
repertoire as well so this is a great
way to keep this repertoire dated it is
not something that is totally set in
stone if someone mentions a problem with
a line I will get a message and I can
address that directly so then for
example now I can easily reply here I
just post a quick thanks here yeah not
not more than that but yeah it's really
in in the Bangko repertoire
there are many remarks now and it really
helped to improve the product yeah so
it's a it's a living it's a living
product it's not set in stone and does
not get updated it gets updated um yeah
this is this is what it is it's as I
said $9.99 at the moment it's a sale
price it will be higher in early 2017
probably with New Year's Day so if you
enjoy the chance of a formal of learning
things and you are interested in the
English this is a great thing to get
also if you actually know the video
series this can be a nice addition to to
learn the lines better okay hope you
enjoyed this overview of this new
product thanks for watching